so the film is in post-production and
are you eating it yourself or you have
some 15 yeah so that our post-production
process is sort of born out of necessity
you know yeah maybe we're not bringing
on a pretty small budget so rad I sit
down together and discuss like the the
film in the arc of the story and how we
went to go and then maurette will
actually do a lot of writing and sift
through interviews and and stuff to sort
of figure out how best that we can tell
the story and then that I do want to
like fiscal editing and then we talk
about the rough cut and then we you know
what change need to be made will show it
to people so it's a very collaborative
process but yeah we're doing it all in
house and kind of all our self at the
moment I think it's been helpful because
I mean I know for me at least you know
working on sort of my new details of
editing and then you know it's really
hard to kind of step back and get
perspective on the bigger story after
you've been looking at the same five
minutes sequence for like 48 hours you
know so I think it's been really helpful
to work that way because we can kind of
you know make decisions and kind of get
different perspectives alada ting
you